buongiorno le parole hanno un
significato alcune parole però sono più
complesse di altre e spiegarle quindi
diventa più complesso io ho sempre
pensato che l'abitare sia una di queste
parole forse una delle più importanti
per noi
ed è per questo che quando si pensa a
queste parole si cerca di immaginare il
loro senso per darne concretezza
anche perché se poi ad esempio nelle
politiche pubbliche dobbiamo passare
dalle parole ai fatti alle attività
bisogna dare senso a queste parole ed è
per questo motivo che la prima volta che
mi hanno nominato il condominio solidale
ho cominciato immaginare cosa potesse
essere e sono partito dal mio condominio
il classico condominio delle nostre
città dove in realtà si ha quasi paura
di incontrare l'altro dove il massimo di
solidarietà e tenere il portone aperto
alla persona che sta arrivando e dove
quasi si ha paura stare 30 secondi
nell'ascensore col proprio vicino
poi la mia mente è volato in brasile
qualche mio amico dice che troppo spesso
la mia mente vola in brasile ma è volata
delle esperienze che ho fatto in favela
sia in altre situazioni cosiddetti
informali dove l'abitazione collettiva è
una delle più innovative soluzioni al di
verbano al bisogno abitativo
anche se oggi la parola che le indica
che i corti sas è una parola spregiativa
perché ovviamente frutto oggi di
situazioni anche informali e illegali
però in realtà recupera una tradizione
del vivere collettivo che era tipico
degli immigrati italiani che vivevano in
famiglia che costruivano la comunità
intorno ad esempio alle nuove fabbriche
che sorgevano a san paolo del brasile
per fare un esempio
quindi la comunità il senso di comunità
in brasile c'è stato un progetto che
voleva trasformare o recuperare le
favelas costruendo condomini una delle
maggiori critiche che è stata fatta
questo progetto e che faceva disperdere
il senso di comunità
seppure in situazioni molto critiche
come potete immaginare delle favelas si
perdeva passando in un condominio il
senso di comunità comunità
qualcuno l'ha definita una parola
maledetta perché per la comunità per
stare nella propria comunità
qualcuno vive vicino ai muri divide le
città
ma è una parola che però dobbiamo
recuperare nel senso appunto proprio del
fare comunità
quindi cos'è abitare
se noi pensiamo alla semantica ci dice
che l'abitare deriva dal latino abitare
con l'acca che significa avere con
contuinità quindi avere una cosa di cui
non solo appunto sia il possesso ma si
trova a suo agio e a nostra disposizione
il luogo dove noi con continuità
costruiamo il nostro vivere nello spazio
ma dove costruiamo le relazioni un'altra
parola molto abusata e innovazione
innovazione appunto che se legate
all'industria la ricerca ci dice che
esiste l'innovazione di processo
l'innovazione di prodotto e ovviamente
anche questa applicata la casa con le
soluzioni domotiche che aiutano la vita
indipendente e l'autonomia
ma l'innovazione legata all'abitare
quindi non solo alla casa all'abitare
significa anche pensare le innovazioni
legate alle reti e alle relazioni e in
questo
possiamo immaginare che proprio una
parola considerata obsoleta vecchia come
solidarietà diventi la parola che si
lega a innovazione innovazione solidale
grazie alla ricostruzione recupero della
solidarietà
ecco infatti i principi ci sono alcune
politiche che provano a metterli in
pratica quella difficoltà delle
politiche ovviamente però da questo
punto di vista anche nel nostro
territorio in friuli venezia giulia a
trieste ci sono delle politiche che
potremmo definire innovative che la
regione appunto al friuli venezia giulia
ha promosso e si chiamano appunto
abitare possibile abitare in autonomia
quello di cui io mi sto occupando in
questo periodo invece un progetto
europeo progetto europeo che si chiama
els che cerca di trovare soluzioni
innovative di housing quindi
dell'abitare e di cura cercando di
mettere insieme i pezzi dell'abitare
quindi la casa e le relazioni lo spazio
la comunità il verde intorno a noi e
questo progetto appunto è fatto con
altri otto paesi con altri partner dei
paesi vicini a noi dell'area del centro
europa con il quale abbiamo trovato
delle sfide comuni queste sfide comuni
sono quelle di questo parlando quindi
l'accessibilità l'accessibilità agli
spazi ma le relazioni allinfo al appunto
all'immateriale l'accessibilità alle
informazioni ea tutto ciò che dobbiamo
conoscere per poter vivere informati
indipendenti e autonomi accessibilità
agli spazi non solo gli spazi urbani ma
anche della propria casa
la vita autonoma e casa è
importantissima per costruire proprio il
proprio luogo di vita
poi ovviamente esistono altre sfide che
sono legate appunto alle persone che ci
stanno intorno che ci possono aiutare e
quindi ci sono nuovi bisogni di
formazione di educazione non solo per i
professionisti ma anche per i cosiddetti
assistenti familiari e l'ultimo e
proprio l'innovazione della comunità
mettere insieme le istituzioni le
organizzazioni le persone che
generalmente lavorano separati lavorano
per settori lavorano per compartimenti
stagni proprio questa idea di rimettere
insieme di integrare persone
organizzazioni e luoghi
una delle innovazioni che stiamo
provando a sostenere a trieste
esattamente il condominio solidale
il condominio solidale
nasce dalla tradizione del cohousing il
cohousing appunto è un termine
anglosassone
anche se la tradizione del condominio
solidale nata in danimarca nel 1972 da
questo punto di housing è diverso da
quelli che sono i condomini normali di
cui ho accennato prima dove viviamo ogni
giorno
ma anche diverso dalle comuni da gli
ecovillaggi proprio perché ha una
caratteristica riesce a mantenere allo
stesso tempo la privacy preservandola
perché uno ha il proprio appartamento
vivere il proprio appartamento e dispone
appunto dal proprio appartamento ma
all'interno di una struttura che rimette
insieme le relazioni e quindi mette
insieme relazioni collettività e privacy
da questo punto di vista quindi ci sono
degli spazi che però sono condivisi e
gli spazi come a trieste stiamo provando
a fare nel condominio solidale del
promosso dall itis che un azienda di
servizi alla persona tra via pascoli e
via conti appunto a trieste dove ci
saranno otto appartamenti che sono
destinati anche a profili diversi ad
esempio ci sono anziani disabili ma
anche giovani studenti dove appunto ci
sono degli spazi comuni tipo una
terrazza dove possiamo immaginare che ci
ritrova la bellezza anche semplicemente
chiacchierare la sera d'estate insieme
quindi cose molto semplici ma che fanno
abitare che fanno comunità
da questo punto di vista e l'innovazione
sta nel fatto che una famiglia che sarà
lì sarà formata adeguatamente a fare
l'animatrice di comunità quindi non solo
più le istituzioni a fare i servizi
informali ma le persone che scambiano
servizi è una famiglia che è lì
animatrici appunto di queste nuove
relazioni di questo nuovo modo di
abitare
abbiamo provato e stiamo provando ad
applicarlo anche un contesto un po
diverso un contesto potremmo dire anche
molto diverso grazie al comune di
trieste all'azienda sanitaria di trieste
e all ater che appunto è l'agenzia
regionale per l'edilizia residenziale
pubblica ma anche grazie a
un'organizzazione che abbiamo coinvolto
che la fondazione luchetta ota d'angelo
hrovatin
abbiamo provato applicare questi
principi stiamo provando applicare
questi principi in un complesso appunto
atlete ci sono 180 appartamenti dove le
persone sono entrate un classico
complesso di edilizia residenziale
pubblica dove appunto alcuni
appartamenti sono stati dati in maniera
specifica
al comune azienda sanitaria però per
avere persone appunto anziane persone
con disabilità ma uno in particolare è
stato dato anche qui a una famiglia che
in cambio appunto del risparmiare
chiamiamola così ma lo metto tra
virgolette appunto perché un valore
sull'affitto da in cambio appunto il
proprio lavoro in quel condominio e
anche lì abbiamo una famiglia che farà
ad esempio l'animatrice comunità
il monitoraggio informale dei bisogni ma
anche l'aiuto il primo punto di contatto
di chi ha qualche bisogno qualche
domanda rispetto all abitare insieme da
questo punto di vista abbiamo provato a
sviluppare questo progetto attraverso un
primo evento che è stata una festa di
primavera di cui vedete le immagini in
cui ad esempio una delle caratteristiche
è stata quella di appropriarsi degli
spazi delle aiuole abbiamo in questi
grandi condomini il grigio e lei vuole
molto spesso hanno delle piantine che
forse resistono bene o male agli anni ma
in realtà noi abbiamo provato a fare in
modo che i cittadini si appropriassero
si apre passo insieme facendo una festa
e quindi costruendo queste relazioni sul
territorio
da questo punto di vista anche abbiamo
provato quindi a colorare il condominio
anche l'estetica abbiamo visto è un
aspetto importante
ecco quindi in realtà il recupero delle
parole e del senso delle parole il
recupero del significato di alcuni
principi con il quale appunto si fanno
le politiche pubbliche si fanno i grandi
discorsi da questo punto di vista vorrei
finire con due parole una recuperata dal
mondo anglosassone
anche qui abusiamo tanto di termini
inglesi ma ce n'è una in particolare che
mi piace sempre che togetherness perché
la solidarietà che appunto significa
solidarieta ma data dal senso di stare
insieme e a me piace tantissimo è
un'altra che in danese e non imparerà
mai a pronunciarla
ma che bofa che skander e spero di
averla sbagliata che significa comunità
vivente
ecco secondo me questo termine della
proprio l'idea della bellezza dello
stare insieme
grazie